[Music]
how's it going Wolfgang it appears that
today we have been given the setting and
the title for a Wonder Woman to by none
other than Geoff Johns himself if you
are not familiar with who Geoff Johns is
he is the president of DC entertainment
and the chief creative officer of DC
entertainment so he's kind of a big deal
and today on Twitter he changed his
background photo to what appears to be
the title of Wonder Woman - not too long
ago Warner Brothers registered a bunch
of domain names for websites that kind
of gave us an idea of what they were
going for for a title for Wonder Woman -
and yes one of those domain names that
was registered by Warner Brothers was
Wonder Woman 1984 dot-com so it seems
that today when Geoff Johns changed his
background photo on Twitter 2ww 84 it
appears that we have our title as far as
setting goes this pretty much confirms
the Cold War setting for 1984 they
worked her into the war in the first
Wonder Woman movie very well so it seems
like they wouldn't have too much
difficulty doing it in the second Wonder
Woman movie there was some chemical
warfare in the first Wonder Woman movie
and it just so happens that in 1984 that
was when President Ronald Reagan called
for an international ban on chemical
weapons so it seems like we might see
something similar to that in Wonder
Woman - what do you all think about this
new recent update that was given to us
by none other than Geoff Johns himself
do you think that this unofficial title
for Wonder Woman - will become the
official title for it and what do you
think about Wonder Woman - setting being
in the Cold War Times hit me with your
thoughts in the comments below and be
sure to like this video and subscribe to
my channel to stay up to date on Wonder
Woman to DC and all thanks superhero
thank you so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
you